vargas gosh rumor has it you read all
three features now i think it's a it's a
record for me it is a record three for
three yeah so we have two covers one of
our covers is about Levi's why don't you
tell everybody what it's about since you
read it basically leave Isis not be
doing so well because companies like
Lululemon and other companies that
produce athleisure wear have been taking
over the market especially women's
markets we got great photos it was
really pretty easy to put together their
lab in San Francisco is pretty
interesting and we got a great photo of
a pair of jeans on a machine and someone
is spray painting it and so we start to
play around with language on it then we
came up with a cover line American booty
which you liked we tried it in kind of
stitching the reference the stitching on
Levi's jeans but it was kind of legible
and so then we went with this kind of
girlie font since the piece is basically
about the women's market and we thought
it worked we also have a European cover
you know tell everybody that's not good
sure there's an airport in Berlin that
apparently has been struggling to open
because of mismanagement and poor
planning it's been delayed for years now
it's well over budget and everyone is
kind of just plenty of girls at each
other yeah we've done a lot of Germany
covers a lot of Greece covers a lot of
Angela Merkel covers and frankly we
couldn't resist doing a cover that's
sort of schadenfreude a from the rest of
Europe about Germany's own miles grew up
right there any other stories you want
to tell people about ok well I will just
point people to two more one is about
Ruth Porat who's the CFO of Google who
came in from Morgan Stanley and has been
there for about three months and yet
somehow the market has responded as if
she is a miracle worker and we just sort
of dive in to what exactly she's done
and I would also point people to our
politics and policy lead which is a
profile of a really boring seeming Bank
which just so happens to be the place of
deposit for everyone running for
president on the GOP side I urge
everyone to read it wrong including you
next we
next week